Hello everybody! my name is Markiplier, and welcome to the official sequel of They Come at Poop Time
And I know you all have been 'eagerly' awaiting to see
What was in store the next time I tried to poop
In the middle of a forest surrounded by demons and monsters-
'The Pooge', 'Harry Pooper', 'Poosific Rim', 'Para-poop-al Activity'...!
Which I'm...I'm assuming that's Paranormal Activity-
And 'Scooby Poo'...
...Ah..
Honestly incredibly wonderful-
variations of (Mark stutters) the 'cult classics'
that we all know of..and love..!
but....
with poo.
I've no- I don't know what the magic word-
is it poo?!
*types poo*
Is poo the magic word?
no?
is it 'poop'?
(Mark forgets to type P-)
Wait- hang on..
Poop.
Damn.
Alright, whatever- 'Pooge'!
'How to Play'
'It's-' (Mark instantly regrets)
'It's that time of year again! The Pooge; everyone is going mental'-
OOOOOOOOH THE PURGE!
(Mark can't comprehend)
You could have just (laugh) called it 'The Purge' and everythin' would have been fine!
'Everyone is going mental, killing those they hate. You are unfortunately hated by everyone.'
Ain't that the truth..
(Stutter and laugh) 'Also!
You just had a huge Mexican meal,
So you've really have to poop.'
'You must defend yourself from intruders, by using traps and repairing damrege!'
'You have 2 cameras set up, with 3 traps each.'
'To use a trap, look at the camera and press 1,2 or 3 on your keyboard-
1 being the first trap, 3 being the last.'
Oh boy! D:
'All traps have to cool down after use- you can see if they are ready by looking at the light under the camera
GreEN MeaNs READY!'
(Mark is trying to process) 'There is also a guy trying to get in via the winDOW!'
'He will CONStantly be breaking the BOOARDS!!'
'(mumble) a board is missing, repair it by looking at the window and spamming E..'-
Oh god..OOWE god...
'The cameras are the main concern, but dont forget the window guy.'
'Use traps wisely as they have a cool-down.'
alRIGHT..
'ere wE GO...
I GUeSS-
oh boy..oh- OOH
It's not free roam D:
(wheeze and laugh)Why do i have..
(Mark can't understand)
Why do i have- oh my god
Ok- oh..hello
ah aH AH-
WHAM MR-woah he ded...
ok- WAHaAAAaaAHA
I MISSED YOU- oh i missed the stoopy stomper-
ok (Markiplier exclusive groan)
got 'em! alright, som guy comi- WHA- oh
oh oh oH OH OH O-OHH-OHOHOH-
(sexual Mark noises)
(The Legend of Markiplier)
ooh...OOPSIES o-o''
ooHH Gawd i've ruined em..
he's gonna get me! EH- he's gonna get me!
no NO NO NO I'M POOPIN' IN EEEERE!! D:<
ha..AAHHH!!
nO!!
I'm..- NO!!
(Mark scare)
Dammit (laughs) they scared me..!
HUAH NAOO!
i'm constipooted!! D:
*wtf*
(laugh) i can't believe... i can't believe that didn't work!
I just need to get coordination versus the traps,
the window, and everything else lookin' at these two..
sooo....ah- WHAM!
hah.. man that's brutal (laughs)
all i want to do is poop!
uh-oh- ok..so we need yOU AND YOU
(amazed Mark noise)
That was a shotgun, i thought that was another ladle!
(Mark mumbles) talk about unnecessary deaths-
ok how are you gonna die?
(Mark noise)
(Mark is now a gorilla)
Vaporize, NAOW!!
GO AWAY!! PLEASE! D':
i'm tryin' ta- uh-oh that aaah i'm boned ALREADY!
i'm boned a- AAH!!
No, I don't want to ta-
plEASE JUST GIVE ME SOME TOILET PAPER AND I'LL BE FIIIIINE!
alright thank you-
i'm now constipated..
a five-minute poop, I mean- seems totally logical to me
I guess that makes utter sense
So I just gotta, i gotta study these ones and i'll get the fence-
Whenever that one comes by...
er just use them as they need be, and whatever you get is what you get
(Mark zoom)
ehhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhHHHHH
I spam dis hard- oook ok. you and you-
ok.
im'gonna get that last one
boink!
ok-
(another Mark noise)
Okay, uh- not on cool-down
and you and you OOOOH
UR DED NOW :D
STOOOOAAAWP!!
that's my sweet poop window!
WHOMP
you're not gonna- (GRUNT) JUST IN TIME!
ey why do they hate me so much?! D:<
I'm just an innocent poop man!
(Mark zoomie)
oh nononononononoo!
man that window-
maybe- something telOAWWW im boner-owned!
ok you and you!...aaand YOU!
aand...aaHHH you!
AWEKAY!
AAAH MY GOD IM FLYIN' BY THE SEAT OF MY ASS!
(Mark references Evil Within 2 playthrough)
AAH GOD I'M GONNA DIE
(Mark repeatedly screaming)
(zoomie)
NAAAOOW!!
soup's in the kitchen...
what clever game mechanics.. (laugh) you gotta admit!
like, for a simple 'shitty' game, literally a SHITTY game...
you-you gotta, you gotta admit, the mechanics are rather..rather 'interesting'
ok, youuuu uh i got another one over there-
do NAWT- oki youu and then you..n' then ok that's cool-down
(Mark groan)
i can't press that faaast enough!
bam!
uh- i missed you but you know-
AAAAHHHH! D:<
(Arnold Schwarzenegger)
ok, im'gonna get you-you and then
1 and then- c'mon YUESS!
oddly enough we're good..and i wouldn't have assumed that..
(anxious Mark)
w-what'd you say??
i don't- i don't wanna do anything to your holes!
(ZOOM)
(stutter) ok- i fixed that apparently
eUGH I ALMOST MISSED THAT
what are you talking about fucknuggets??!
(British accent) don't be talkin' about my fucknuggets!
uuh im gonna wait til the last one for you and the first two for you!
and that one for you!
EUGH- I GOTTA POOP IN 220?!
220?!
THAT'S HARDLY ENOUGH POOP TIME!!
bonk!
wonk!
GET BLONKED!!
if i just keep spamming- ooooohhh...i'm on cool-down ok
boink!
k annd..blonk.. est- NO!
that was not meE!!
(zoomer)
dammit i missed that one- ok-
AARG GET U!!
yes >:D
aagh not get you!
ok- (Mark noises)
ok- (noise)
i need to get that one-
later..later, as is..RRIGHT NOW!
(noise)
(how many zooms my gosh-)
that sounded bad... okay, ahhh shit I got split em up-
1 there, idgt- AAHHH missed- oh NO
OH NOO!
k you, ahh...
okay, I don't know if spamming after the fact- this is so stress inducing!
i don't even know why! it's just a game about poop!
ok- thu-
i'd like to think that thunk is preemptive, and helping me.. because if it's not.. theeen..
it's naaaaht.. (Mark doesn't know)
well, glad i answered that conundrum for everybody at home who was- curious about the status of whether or not i'm boNED OR NOT!!
you...
(growl)
(French accent) no soup for you!
who new i had so many people to soup in this town!
WHAM!
WUMBO WHAM!
WHAM!- oh
oops, i'm out
you...i'm not gonna miss yoU!
your...bloody fucknuggets?
i don't want to know about your bloody fucknuggets...
don't talk about (Scottish accent?) your.. fooknuggets... when I am around
k, 3, 1 OOOH!
OH NO!-
OH God ok, i'm-i'm good i'm good
(Mark mumbles about being good)
you- oh no..
i'm bad. i'm bad. i'm bad. i'm bad. i'm dead. i'm dead. i'm dead i'm dead-
URGH GOT YA
wwwumpis
wumpy-woo, wumpy-woo for you!
eughhh
oooOOooph~
uh-oh this bad-
oh this' bad-
oh this' bad
ok, you and then... you and then You, ok!
ARHHH i still got a chance! BUT I'M ONE MINUTE AWAY FROM POOP TOWN!!
i guess this is Poop Town USA, but whatever..
(Mark noise)
oh god! i just missed that one- Oh, I cannot miss the first one or the next one-
ahh ahhH AHH AHHH
I MISSED THE FIRST ONE AND THE NEXT ONE!! OOH I JUST DID EXACTLY WHAT I SAID I SHOULDN'T DO-
oh no- please PLEASE AOHH PLEASE!!
plEASE I'M TRYIN' TO POOP! I'M SO CLOSE TO POOP TOWN!!
NAHH- OHH
(Mark is constipated)
Get smooshed!
get smooshed, im'gonna put you in the soup pot!!
you get smooshed!
i'm not in the Upside-down, what are you talking about the 'Upside-down'?
that was the most stressful-
('nother zoom)
ttthSTOPP! you made me mess up- ok
oh please please- ok ya know, that's fine-
cuz i'm gonna get you! ima get you! ima get you!
NAAHH!
POOP IN 20 SECONDS-
ahHH- i've never be- (Mark breathes)
i've never been this concerned about the status of my poop!
i bet the whole internet has never been this stressed about the status of MY poop!
please tell the world about the status of my poop! t-minus five seconds to poop time!
don't don't don't..annnd...don't!
HEYY!! :D
IE POOPED! :DD
i pooped! i pooped guys!
guys tell the world!!
Markiplier pooped and everybody's happy!
remember that guys- V. V is the first magic number-letter
(Mark stutters) magic number wumber- number 1, wumper dumper 1..
(burp)
is...V....
'You are the boy who didn't die. You just saved the world from you don't know who.'
'Now your next challenge awaits, you need to poo on the Hogfart.. (instant regret)
(Mark has many regrets this video)
alright.
'you need- you need to poo on the Hogfart Express.'
'You need to use the spells they taught you at Hogfart to survive the toilet.'
'Fart...mon..ters..
(regret)
(ZOOM)
'Teachers and Pooperin... all seek to embarrass you OR kill you.'
(laugh)
one or the other! you're either gonna be horribly embarrassed, or dead. ya know, really a toss-up
'Fartmon-ters', god stop that-  'will try and get in through the window, quickly use spell 2 to get rid of them.'
alright,
'The Teachers will sometimes walk by and knock on the door, you have to answer them by pressing E on the door.'
'The Pooperin'... will sometimes-oh Slytherin...right..
'will sometimes throw stink bombs inside if you breathe in too much, you will get knocked out.'
'You must use spell number 1 to create a shield around you that blocks the stinky gas.'
'The stink bomb will appear at the bottom of the door. Because you are on an old train, the doors will sometimes open due to turbulence.'
'If the teacher reaches the door and it's open, he will GET you.'
'Use spell 3 to put the door back'- WHY??!
Harry Pooper??! and the...
Poppiner of Askapoop?
Harry Pooper and the..Goblet of Poop? (laughs)
You know in the movie, Dumbledore's like-
"DID YA POOT UR NEEEME..IN THE GOBLET OF POOP?!"
okay, anyway, let's give this a goO!
alright i'm ready!
"Bertie Butts: almost every flavor beans"
Whoo, "Buttbeer: only 9.9- NO.
"Poop in"...
NOOO
uh-oh!
woa- spell number..th-3!
am i- was that spell number 3??!
i don't know what's happening!
noo!!
dooor- uh-oh that ain't good
i'm creating a shield i think? i'm not creating-
i- wha- SHIEEEELLLD!!
SHHEEEE....AHHH!
ohh..that's not good. oh, that's a Poop-Menter isn't it- GET AWAY!
back! back ye demon let me poop!
(major Mark scare)
All righty then!
obviously, there's many more amazing game modes left, in this here game..
uh..
so.. let me know down the comments (laugh)
if you want to see more of it!
also, I wanted to take a second
i  know it's... awkward to take a second and get kind of serious at the end of a frickin' poop related game?
but i just wanted to say thank you,  again :)
i mean, i thanked you guys endlessly in the thank-you video, but i wanted to say thank you guys again
because i've always said that this community is the most amazing community on YouTube
and i stand by those words, because not only do you guys let ME..
take the time i need to..
just find myself, and find what i want to do and take a break if i need to- and then come back stronger than ever
and have fun with making videos again, and try new things
You guys extend that to the rest of the community
You know, even if I don't notice fan art or-or stories or.. or gifts or things like that
or community creations like animation, you guys let me know about it, or you guys just say how good it is or how great
people have progressed in the community as artists, and creators themselves and..
there are so many opportunities like that that you would never see in any other community
and i'm eternally grateful for that :) and i want to see more of it!
i would love to see more of that carry through into every other aspect of what we do here and
every avenue of the community. and even if you're just here to watch games or watch sketches or whatever, that's great to!
just thank you guys for being here, and I can't wait to make more cool stuff for you ;)
so thank you everybody so much for watching!
let me know if you want to see more poop games down the comments below, and as always.. i will see YOU in the next video..
Buh-Bye!! :D